give me a big picture thought on the
first game that we saw
bucks over the packers 31-26 well like
all right first off i
i do want to just like this the stars
aligned i mean just like that what
you're talking about
right there brady i mean everything the
way this season shook out
the roller coaster ride i mean it's
amazing first off
what they've done that's amazing tom
brady's amazing
he's 10 years in the super bowl that's
insane i mean
i don't even know you can't even
quantify that that's unreal
and then i do want to just say this mike
before i give a big picture of the game
just like congratulations to tampa bay
seriously i they have a special place in
my heart the glazier family
they do they try to do everything right
they're great owners
it's a great football city so i'm happy
to see that i really am
big picture hey jaworski hey you're not
getting a ring if they win
i know i know assistant don't don't try
it's too late now i just want a picture
in like
the the medical room is like the
toughest sob
on in franchise history or something
like that that's all i'm asking for
but other than that big picture of the
game mike
i think the thing that i'll always come
back to the buccaneers
the size the physicality of the game all
the big hits all the
must win type moments tampa one
throughout the game on both sides of the
ball and i know we're gonna unpack them
all but there was many
crazy situations and i think my big
picture in the game would be this mike
really it comes down to the two
quarterbacks we know this it's one
quarterback who's got to play perfect
for his team to win
and another quarterback you know it's a
microcosm of these guys careers
doesn't have to play perfect doesn't
even necessarily have to play great or
good
and they can still win um so that jumps
out to me as a big picture thought of
the game as well
and one coach who trusts his quarterback
to get it done apparently when the
opportunity is there and another one
who apparently does not and that's going
to be one of the big themes of the day
and one of the things down unpacked
let's flip it over to the late game
big picture takeaway from the well let's
we're talking bucks packers we'll talk
about chiefs bills later all right the
the uh
then there is so much to ponder here and
you know it could have been one of the
great
playoff comebacks of all time not quite
bill's oilers
from 28 years ago but down 18
points early third quarter when it felt
like it was over it was done
that's when it all started to swing
green bay's way and
i would have bet at some point mid late
third quarter early fourth quarter
they're gonna pull it off it's over the
bucs had their chance that's it
you can't have interceptions on three
straight possessions tom brady and
expect to fend off this packers team and
aaron rodgers
and that what makes what makes to me the
ability of the buccaneers to hold on and
win the game
even more impressive because they had to
hold on with everything they had because
brady all of a sudden wasn't getting it
done for him
the defense had to step up and preserve
what ultimately was a five-point victory
well i think that's exactly what it was
and that's why
they're going to the super bowl they're
a complete team they don't rely on one
guy
all the time and there's another team
that has to rely on one guy
to really put pressure on the other team
it's their their their biggest
you know peace in the chess game but
tampa yes
you know their defense was the
difference in the football game
yesterday
i mean of course we know about the
interception but just so many big
moments
you know there like you're talking about
the game's 28-23
the packers got the ball two times with
a chance to go take the lead
and you know within that couldn't do it
and the big reason
was because of that buccaneers defensive
line they all day were
over all over rogers pressuring him
whether it was just a four-man rush or a
five-man rush they won that battle up
there and it was just a great total team
win for tampa bay
all together it started early on the
first drive they sacked aaron rodgers
right up with five sacks
three for shaq barrett two for jason
pierre paul and you typically don't see
aaron rodgers
get knocked around like that but it did
come down to
a critical decision that that followed a
critical third down play when it was 31
to 23
yeah the packers driving they had the
ball
third and eight and it was a pass thrown
by aaron rodgers to devante adams at the
time when
many thought he could have run right but
one of the reasons he didn't run is he
thought they had
two downs not one down to score he
thought they were gonna go for the
touchdown not the field goal
let's let's hear a mashup of of some of
the folks who were on the field and or
a key person on the sideline and matt
lafleur making the decision
to call for the field goal unit when it
was 31-23
fourth and eight and the packing of the
pack and ears the packers could have
scored
with a two-pointer and forced overtime
here they are was pretty surprised just
based on how the team
how the game went i mean i felt like
there was multiple plays throughout the
course of the game that
they were letting us play man i haven't
seen a replay but from what i was told
there was a tug there
whether the the ball was catchable or
not
i mean i think that always goes into it
but
bottom line the official made the call
and that's what it is
that's not the right sound um but that's
okay we'll
we'll get there we'll know we'll get
there that's about the cause let's do it
pass your fingers let's
talk about that later let's no let's
let's let's get back to what we're
talking about the decision to kick the
field goal
instead of going for the touchdown
fourth and goal here it is yeah
it was just the circumstances of having
three shots
and coming away with no yards
and knowing that you not only need the
touchdown but you need the two point
so the way i was looking at it was
we essentially had four timeouts with
the two minute warning
and you know we we knew we needed to get
a stop and i thought we were gonna have
a stop there at the end but
you know they we got cold for for the pi
um and it didn't work out so
i think anytime something doesn't work
out do you regret it
sure but we're always going to be
process driven here and the way our
defense was battling
the way our defense was playing felt
like it was the right decision to do
and it just didn't work out i understand
thinking about two minutes with uh all
of our timeouts but
yeah that wasn't my decision i couldn't
believe it honestly because there's no
guarantee that they're gonna make it
back down there again even if they was
on fourth down they might as well
try but uh i know offense pretty
they've been amazing in four-minute
offense this year not giving the team
back the ball
so i had all the utmost confidence in
them but uh
i know they if he could take it back he
probably who wouldn't do that next time
but i appreciate it
office did their job we did our job and
we came up with the one
this is where the rubber meets the road
when we look at things from an
analytical
standpoint the idea that there were the
three time outs plus the two-minute
warning the idea that all we needed was
a stop we're down 31-26 we get the ball
back
we go down and have a game-winning
touchdown don't need a two-point
conversion
to force overtime i understand all that
in the abstract if we're having the
philosophical conversation about how to
manage a game i understand it
don't necessarily agree with it but i
understand it yeah right what causes me
to make my final decision is
understanding that wait who do i have on
fourth and goal from the eight i have
aaron rodgers
okay check mark in favor of going for it
and who's on the other team that's right
if we
kick the field goal and give them the
ball and all they need is a first down
or two it's tom brady
okay another check mark i'm going for it
right on fourth and goal
i'm winning the game with the ball in my
guy's hands
and not trying to win the game with the
ball in their guys hands when it's the
battle of goats
right when it's the two best who ever
played
that's the easy decision and i think
that's one of the reasons why aaron
rodgers chose his words very carefully
and he said more about the play than
just what we played
right he he look he's being a good
soldier here it's not his decision but
he said the reason he threw the ball on
third
and goal is he thought he had another
play right he didn't even consider the
possibility
at that point in the game with a little
over two minutes left
that they were going to kick a field
goal down eight points who does that
especially
with those two quarterbacks involved
well we know who does matt laflord yeah
well yeah you're right i mean
that that was the game i mean you know
hey i know that the offense had been
somewhat successful in the second half
but it you know
had not been successful really for a
long period of time until that drive
right there to get them down there in
that position
you know there's no guarantee like shaq
barrett just said there's no guarantee
they're gonna get the ball back and
drive down again i mean we saw a lot of
stale parts of the
the game for that green bay offense but
ultimately and mike i mean i think
it just comes down to what you said it's
fourth and eight
you know you're you're there
for one reason and he said it later on
in a press conference the heart
and soul of our team is aaron rodgers
you're there for one reason you're in
that game for one reason
you go down swinging with your best
punch
that's what you do he's your man okay
we can talk about him scrambling or
shouldn't have run on third down
whatever that we'll talk about that in a
second
but either way that's my thought there
and i think you you laid it out
perfectly
yes we have aaron rodgers check wait
they have another guy who
hold on oh that's right has been closing
games out for 20 years
let's check and not see that happen uh
that's where
you know i i it's wrong that's where
it's wrong there's no other way to say
it's not egregiously wrong
the things in the way he explained it he
is correct
the defense was playing well and all
those things i mean there's nothing
wrong with what he said
but i think at the end of the day it's
still a decision that he's going to look
back and go man
i should have gave my best player the
ball and the biggest play of the game
and see if he could have won the game or
at least tied the game for us
aaron rodgers has an 80 success rate in
the red zone one of the best of all time
and rogers at one point explained
because they asked him because we've
seen and i think back to the
baltimore seattle game from last year
when lamar jackson kind of
kind of asserted himself and it was a
fourth down
and remember he's doing this to john
harbaugh and the field goal team
and they asked aaron rodgers about and
he was like well i look over and i see
these five big guys coming out and
there's too many things happening
mechanically i
and and look i know aaron rodgers is
your guy and i agree with you he's one
of the greats of all time
but i think about that moment like
do is that a moment where you assert
yourself if you're one of the all-time
greats does tom brady say
get to the sideline does peyton manning
say get to the sideline
that was an opportunity for aaron
rodgers to assert himself and he didn't
he he's a good soldier he stays within
the lines
but i you know again i'm not
doing it because because it's it's
difficult to do it it's difficult to do
it
but we've seen guys do that i we have
and and we've seen him do it we've seen
i think he he explained it just the
right way though
like i think if he sees the head coach
over there kind of
hemming and hawing right like oh i don't
know what to do he's going to go come on
go for it are you crazy
but he throws the pass he looks back
over and the field goal
unit's running on the field right so now
they're not gonna be like hey hold on
hold on and then waste the time out and
do all that stuff
so that's where he was stuck i think he
was giving you a total honest answer
there
and we're talking about a guy who come
on
i mean all we've talked about his whole
career is he's oh well he always says
what he wants he always tells him what
he wants to do it's all about aaron
rodgers so
i i think he would have done that if
they just i think the situation wasn't
right and he felt like it was a little
unorganized and it wouldn't be right for
him to say hold on
wait leave me out here you guys run back
off i think it was just discombobulated
that way
they still had three timeouts and the
two-minute warning if they had burned
one to get it right in that moment
and and look we haven't talked about
this yet but if you go for it
and you don't make it the buccaneers are
pinning they're backed up
right inside the 10. you got a better
chance of getting the ball back in that
setting are they going to take chances
and maybe they will
maybe that's what matt lafleur is
thinking we're going to give these guys
the ball on the eight yard line and
they're just gonna
but see that same logic applies if you
kick off to them
like they're still gonna no risk it no
biscuit they're still gonna throw it on
third down they're still gonna try to
deliver the dagger whether they have the
ball
on the eight up eight right or on the 25
up
five it doesn't matter they're still
going to be who they
are and that needs to get factored into
it i would love to be able to peel back
the curtain and understand
how the decision was made how much
thought was put into it how much
planning was put into it
who was talking to matt lafleur about
this because
i don't even know i haven't you know
from an analytic standpoint you could
make the argument that
that it's it's you go for it i mean how
many times it seems like any time we
fall back on analytics based on our
argument it is you go forward on fourth
down right that's it
oh analytics i've never heard enough
otherwise i've never heard otherwise
that's my problem with it
i've never heard you don't go for it
i've never but but in this case i
understand why you wouldn't
if their quarterback was jameis winston
not tom brady i understand it completely
but it's tom brady we've seen him
convert
third downs all day long he was
converting third down after he thrives
in that moment
so you're going to take a guy who has
played now
44 postseason games 44 single
elimination games in his career
more games than most players ever get in
in the nfl when you look at the
full scope of the guys drafted and
signed his free agents guys don't play
in 44 games in the regular season he's
played in 44 in the postseason
he lives for that moment he loves that
moment you're giving him the ball back
up
five and yeah so you get ten timeouts
who cares well
i i okay i hear you mike and you know
you're you're laying it out here
perfectly too because where i just want
to go
you know that that kind of talks to what
matt lafleur's logic was as well
like i want to be like no matt you know
yeah
you guys got three turnovers in a row it
wasn't like dominant defense it was just
three bad throws by tom brady
they were open they were moving the ball
if he throws the ball down the middle to
mike evans he's wide open
they're gonna have the ball at the four
yard line they're gonna score a
touchdown the game's gonna be over
so they weren't just like oh look at
they're stopping him nobody's open
come on brady fell down and and then off
his back foot and threw a ball and
nobody touched him for an interception
he missed mike evans down the middle
wide open it barely went off his
fingertips uh so
you know that speaks to what you're
saying too nonetheless that the defense
wasn't that dominant and that brady was
still going to be able to make the play
when he needed to and wanted to
he wasn't going to be rattled by the
three interceptions you know and
to me mike that's the big thing of the
game it's we saw
one team that from the get-go was
throwing their body around
physical was you know shining under the
bright lights of the nfc championship
game we're going we're attacking
and we had another team that was a
little bit like
hesitant i don't know what else to say
bruce aryan's team
the culture around it is more for these
type of football games than we're seeing
you know the matt lefleur hey we have to
execute
perfectly and aaron rodgers has to
execute perfectly or we can't win the
football game type attitude
and the 49ers and the buccaneers two
years in a row showed you
like no this game's about emotion and
physicality and it just can't be about
one guy having to play perfect to win
your game there's got to be more to it
and i think that's one thing to just
look at for the overall mantra of the
game that the buccaneers brought to it
that the buck
that the packers didn't have and that's
a great point no risk get no biscuit may
not get you there
but if you get there oh they're losing
no biscuit is gonna help you
tremendously right
yeah i i do believe so you know i it's
it's there's certain things about
certain coaches where
yeah he's just fearless you know what
what do you say the identity of his team
was last week were some bad mofos or
whatever the hell he was like that's all
it was
yeah great we're gonna go to green bay
we're gonna kick their butt they don't
doubt that
you know and so there is something to
that and uh
a toughness and everything about the
buccaneers yesterday was very impressive
and of course that goes to bruce arians
and brady and everybody involved
and tom brady did have three
interceptions they all were his fault
you may not have gleaned that from
watching the game they all were his
fault we're allowed to say that
he's not going to come with that beat
you up right he's not going to send you
a nasty text message and if he does
you respond by saying hey tom they were
your fault you won the game
congratulations all three of those
interceptions
were your fault the first one was sailed
long enough for adrian amos to run over
and pick it off
there wasn't even double coverage he
didn't throw into double coverage it
became double coverage because the ball
was sailed for so long
the second one was a high ball to mike
evans that he tried to catch it looked
like it was his fault
it was tipped it was intercepted and the
third one was darnell savage on a blitz
and and tom brady just fired it up into
the air
and he hung it up long enough for for jr
alexander to make a play on the ball and
mike evans was wondering where the hell
is the footballs they're all his fault
he's had four playoff games now with
three interceptions and he's three and
one
in those crazy he's thrown three
interceptions which tells you it helps
to have a good team around you
and it helps to forget about it that's
the key yeah you forget about it
and so you know matt lafleur may have
thought hey we're going to get
interception number four well brady's
never thrown four interceptions in a
playoff game and no
season's on the line game's on the line
legacy's on the line
and even though he didn't throw a
completed pass he drew the pass
interference penalty played the sound
earlier matt lafleur talking about the
call and
look here's here's the problem most
people have because i don't think
there's any dispute
that there was past interference any
time you see as somebody pointed out on
twitter a large jersey become an
xl by virtue of the tug on tyler johnson
as he tried to get to the football
that's pass interference the argument is
they weren't calling the game tight all
game long
why are they throwing the flag in the
moment where
you know in past years we'd say this is
where you tuck the flag deeper in the
pocket look at that
look at that no that's not fast
interference but chris what do you say
to the argument that they'd been letting
things go all day they should have let
it go in that's well yeah i mean
listen they did let it go all day it's
it's one of my things and my pet peeves
would play all football
all of a sudden the refereeing style
changes and now
offenses don't know what to expect
because they're like wait
all of a sudden we're allowed to hold
and hit every play i didn't
we weren't allowed to do this for 17
weeks so that's a confusing thing
regardless
but regardless of that the game i
appreciate that they let people play and
do those things
my thought here mike is that was a hair
too egregious just to tuck your flag
away
you know again if it was a little just
holding and grabbing
and maybe a little pulldown down the
shoulder and things like that okay yeah
that's been going on all game long
there's no doubt you know and there was
there was plenty of
plays where we could have called past
interference but this to me in that
moment just goes above and beyond the
little bit of like
hand fighting put pulling pushing
touching that type of stuff
this is a true wait i've pulled you down
to slow you down
change the course you're on and made
myself faster in the process as well to
make a play on the football
i have no problem with the call it
shouldn't have gotten there
to that point anyways like we've talked
about and kevin king had a very very
rough day all together let alone just
that play
two more points on the call one i don't
agree with i saw someone saying
well i got a problem with the fact that
they waited so long to throw the flag
like they waited to see if the ball was
actually caught well who cares
interference is interference
it doesn't matter how long it takes you
to dig the flag out of your pocket and
throw it if you think it's interference
it's interference there's no statute of
limitations
other than you know the next play i
think you probably have to throw the
flag before the next play
and there is a point where it becomes
painfully awkward if you wait 5 10 15 20
seconds but i don't have a problem with
that
what about the issue and aaron rodgers
talked about this
in expressing his opinion it was a bad
call he thought the ball was uncatchable
now sometimes uncatchable
is skewed by the fact that the player
was impaired from his ability to try to
catch it so it makes it look uncatchable
do you think it was uncatchable you know
i i'd like to watch it again
and really get a look out of it like a
coach's film it was close to that it was
close
i understand what they're arguing you
know but at the same time
he's throwing a touch ball where he
thinks a guy's running in one certain
direction and like you just said
is pulled in another direction all
together to where
he can't adjust his body or even get
close to make it look like
or you know catchable that that's really
the only way to say it
so i i don't know yet i'd like to watch
it a few more times but i i felt like
just in real time
that it was the right call and when i
saw the replay
i went man they they haven't been
calling this all day but
this is you know too egregious just to
let go with a guy's arm totally extended
and then all he can barely do is grab
the guy's t-shirt
that's hanging out underneath his jersey
and now that's extended another few feet
like come on that's that's past
interference and that was as bad as any
we saw
all day it wasn't just the normal things
we saw let go throughout the game
and and look i don't want to try to
rewrite the rule book on the fly but i
feel like there's a gap there
when it is uncatchable and it's not past
interference but you have an egregious
hold like that
i know that holding goes off once the
ball's in the air and in theory
if the ball is uncatchable you can hold
grab tug pull the guy down lay him out
it doesn't matter i mean you can't you
know you can't hit him
improperly because he's defenseless but
if it's uncatchable all bets are off i
just feel like something like that
like there should be a rule against it
even if it's uncatchable
because you clearly held the guy you
clearly
you clearly restricted his movement at a
time when he's trying to go get the
football but regardless it was past
interference
the drive extended the buccaneers were
able to put the game away
and now tom brady becomes the fourth
quarterback to reach the super bowl with
multiple teams and uh he's going to get
a chance it's incredible
to win uh a seventh
and a first with an nfc team um
people were you know people making all
kind of observations last night
including that
brady has won as many nfc championships
as aaron rodgers
um but uh you know it's kind of stuff
you're going to hear in the aftermath of
something like this
and and you have to wonder number one
how rogers is feeling we're going to
talk about that coming up but
how is brady feeling right now when you
consider
you know he made the bet now he picked
the destination it was the perfect spot
for him if he just stayed in new england
maybe they don't make the playoffs right
and if they do they're not going to get
very far they're not playing the chiefs
yesterday
if they make the place they don't have
enough people around him he found a spot
where he had enough around him offensive
and defensive
to get to where he wanted to be period
right and uh
you know it was it was all set up that
way you know we were looking at
destinations and when you start thinking
about the buccaneers last march it's
like hey this makes a ton of sense
yeah and as unthinkable as it is it's
still weird to see his
face in front of that logo i still want
to say patriots
when i think of tom brady but you know
after we see him play in a super bowl
that may finally put that to rest yeah
well i mean he'll
always be the patriots tom brady there's
no doubt about that but this is un
unreal i mean again to go to two super
bowls with two different franchises
is an enormous feat in itself it really
is let it go
let alone you know you've gone the nine
super bowls with one other and now
here's one other team
you squash a lot of the talk of like it
was only belichick
which of course we know it wasn't only
belichick yeah maybe belichick deserves
more of the credit but brady's right you
know brady was amazing there's nothing
there's nothing more to be said about
that he is without a doubt
like the most accomplished quarterback
we've ever seen we've never seen anybody
do it
as good as he has consistently as good
as long as he has
there's no arguing that yeah you're not
going to hear me say
he's the greatest quarterback of all
time just because he has the most
accomplishments
sorry no i'm not you know you know
yesterday like we talked about is a
microcosm of two guys careers that kind
of just says it all
it just says it all one guy's got to
play perfect
the other guy always has had the ability
to go ah
it's not all of me we got i got other
guys that can help me and that's what
stinks for aaron rodgers i felt about as
bad for a professional sports athlete
last night mike
for aaron rodgers as i have in a long
long time for any sports athlete i
really have because i know the chatter
that's going to be around him
you laid it out there you know but the
relax
the reality is he's played in one nfc
championship game where his team was the
better
team on the field and a lot of these nfc
championship games
they had their the the gear they lose to
atlanta they're a six and ten
seven and nine football team they have
aaron rodgers they're great he can't
kick you know catch the onside kicks
it's just unfortunate
it's the way it is and i i think he's
devastated he should be and all i kept
thinking about sorry while we're on this
just last thing
i just kept thinking man man what if one
of those first round picks was a corner
or like or a defensive tackle or
of something that might have helped in
the game yesterday a first round pick
and a fourth round pick last year
devoted to the eventual replacement of
aaron rodgers and by
the nfc championship game they would
have been going into
game number 19 they're not rookies
anymore now they could have been injured
they could have not been good but still
you don't know
you traded in those lottery tickets for
a guy who contributes
nothing to the game now you filibustered
there for a little bit sorry
it's not going to lead me past the point
i want to make i don't know whether it's
a
sims-ism or we need to come up with a
different word because sports athlete
like is there another kind of athlete
that i'm not aware of i don't know you
said it like two or three times
i don't know sports athletes i don't
know why i said i don't
and i'm foggy sorry can we call it a
sims dundancy i don't know
we have a new category of the dictionary
but uh anyway
um yeah look those are all fair
points for us to raise and
those thoughts surely have rattled
around
in the very large and
able and complicated brain of aaron
rodgers since
late april when that trade was made a
one and a four
to move up to get jordan love and that
one and a four could have come in handy
yesterday for the green bay packers
offensive defense of whatever the case
may be
and you know you think about
what a comeback it was and the packers
were on the other end of one of those
six years ago in seattle yeah when
everything was going green bay's way
and seattle came back and they took it
now it was in overtime
but the mentality was throw it to the
end zone
be aggressive and i think that may be
what sticks in aaron rodgers craw
because
when you consider the background before
the decision to kick the field goal on
fourth down instead of go for the
touchdown
and it started not just when the fumble
happened
in the early third quarter that made it
28 to 10 and set the stage for the
recovery by the packers it was the no
risk get no biscuit the ultimate
bruce arians screw it let's throw it
deep
to scotty miller we haven't had that yet
kevin king right
and that was the moment where it felt
like the hakeem knicks hail mary from
the 2011
right divisional round game where it's
like it's just not green bay's day
it's just not green bay's day it's going
to be a big buccaneers win the question
is how many they're going to win by
and they got the look that they liked
they they called them what is it like
the look what is the look it looks
literally like hey
hey run by us and try to score a
touchdown here guys well
there's one safety there's one safety
right i mean at least it's not greg
williams blitz everybody but it seems
like it's something that comes out of
the greg williams loser mentality which
is you know let's just let the other
team run right by
us which is what they ultimately did
well like
why isn't there two safeties back i i
don't know exactly
i don't know why aren't there three well
they did they didn't
look they they didn't want to give up
the quick out
see this is the perfect spot to throw
deep because they're thinking
you're gonna try to get another 10 yards
right to get a closer field goal
they're not thinking scotty miller is
going to run by kenny king
kevin king excuse me and score a
touchdown well they're not thinking that
apparently i don't
obviously they weren't kevin king's been
run by the whole first half
the whole first half they ran by him the
whole first drive was just
kevin king atrocities there was already
a dropped
in your hands interception by the
secondary at that point
they weren't playing good why yeah we
know they want to get
you know five yards for more for the
field goal whatever
you know if i'm if memory serves me
correct they did have one timeout still
at that point right
two right mike i i believe they did so
is that correct does anybody did i hear
you no they out
yeah they're out of time okay i made it
even more of a risk it for the biscuit
it actually makes it even dumber for
green bay
like why would you not be playing a two
safety defense and be protecting the
sideline then
why that makes no absolutely no sense
why would you let them do that that to
me i mean we've hit on it
that was just again another moment of
one team aggressive
shining under the lights playing loose
we're coming here to win the game
and not coming here to not lose it that
was the difference and that was the
mentality and the physicality
of the buccaneers compared to to green
bay all day yesterday
and i inadvertently mentioned kenny king
earlier you may remember him as the guy
who held for 16 years the record for the
longest touchdown catch in super bowl
history an 80 yarder for the raiders
against the eagles in super bowl 15 a
record that was broken
by brett favre to antonio freeman 81
yards in super bowl 31. that's a
delayed recovery on my part but i meant
to say kevin i said kenny but i
remembered kenny
as a star for the raiders in that super
bowl win so scotty miller a guy who
it seems like every game he's in number
one he barely plays
and number two he's making a long catch
with this kind of
fetal position like he you never see him
lay out you never see him jump up you
never see him extend his arms it's this
kind of
crouching fetal ball comes in and he
catches it and rolls
and he's behind somebody every time he
does it and it's always more than 25
yards down the field
are they going to cover this guy at some
point i would suggest that the chiefs
and steve spagnolo begin planning now
for the inevitable moment when scotty
miller is going to run behind somebody
and catch a 40-yard pass
in 13 days we hit on it last week we
said you know we didn't think there was
going to be a drop-off between him and
antonio brown right
we said i'm not sure if antonio brown
can run a go route and run like scottie
miller
i mean it's debatable as you saw he can
legitimately go
but you know still the point is
and i mean i'm i'm even more like
astounded now that i've i've you know
processed and wait there's no timeouts
right
that defense is that is a total
mismanagement of the situation there
that makes no sense at all if they have
no timeouts
why are we protecting the middle of the
field with a middle safety and two
linebackers in the middle
like you said have three safeties deep
play really deep okay you can challenge
the out routes and stop those things if
they throw a ball
in bounds the half is over i mean it's
over
you've let you actually played they
played a defense to allow them
to throw the out route or the go route
they actually said here wait
did you guys want to stop the clock
we'll play a defense to let you stop it
that's what they did crazy mistakes like
that all day with green bay it's like
do you think yeah i don't know do you
think they were trying to bait them
into throwing it deep and not take the
out route thinking they wouldn't
complete
the deep maybe i don't know i you're
right maybe they were thinking yeah
they'll be aggressive they'll take a
shot and we'll get out of here and
you know they'll have no time in the
clock or they'll have to kick a 57-yard
field goal
maybe um but man the way that secondary
played like to what you mentioned with
all the third down conve
conversions and the way kevin king
looked at that point i just wouldn't
have trusted any of that
aspect of my football team at that point
yeah look it was an amazing moment and
and it made as i mentioned earlier
what the packers did to get it down to
eight points
yes even more impressive and when you
god i you know look matt lafleur is a
great coach
it doesn't diminish what he's
accomplished right but
it it's hard not to be upset as a
football fan
because that decision deprived all of us
of what could have been one hell of a
moment they score on that play
they have the two-point conversion they
score on that
and then we're 31 all heading to
overtime in the nfc
championship are you kidding me after an
18-point deficit
are you kidding me and uh
it's not it's not quite as bad
as what the seahawks had to overcome
from super bowl 49 but i think matt
lafleur is going to have some work to do
to because i think as time goes by it's
going to be one of those things where
today tomorrow the next day guys start
reflecting guys
yeah they're going to get they're going
to blow this they're going to get more
upset about it right they are
they're going to look at it in a lot of
ways and not to take anything away from
tampa they certainly made a lot of their
own luck and made a lot of big plays
and with the tougher physical team out
there but man yeah green bay as we know
it's a sport that
you always self-reflect they're going to
look back at it and go wow did we
blow it in a lot of big moments during
that football game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports